venir en famille prendre le temps de
flâner à travers les rayons emprunter
tranquillement cbdc roman pour le mois à
venir
depuis septembre l'ouverture de la
bibliothèque municipale de tours un
dimanche par mois
séduit les tourangeaux sur mes horaires
de travail c'est pas tout le temps
facile pour moi d'aller à la
bibliothèque
donc là le fait que ça soit ouvert une
fois par mois je trouve que c'est
amplement suffisant
voilà et je trouve ça vraiment super de
pouvoir offrir ce service
ici à tour les musées sont ouverts le
dimanche pourquoi pas les bibliothèques
enfin voila c'est
après il faut voir si le public de tours
pour pour les gens de tours s'est adapté
et puis s'ils vont s'en saisir s'il veut
revoir ça c'est un micro je trouve ça
très bien du point de vue des usagers
c'est très pratique de pouvoir venir
avec les enfants après avoir occupé le
samedi plutôt au niveau des magasins
après j'espère que c'est pas trop de
contraintes pour les les employés dans
l'ensemble c'est plutôt contents super
joué beaucoup et j'aime beaucoup de
livres parfois qu'est ce que tu as
choisi aujourd'hui choisi beaucoup de
livres qui font taire pour s'ouvrir un
nouveau public la bibliothèque propose
aussi des animations
l'heure du conte où la sieste musicale
avec vue sur loire le moment de dévorer
sa bd ou son livre préféré
les adultes s'endorment les enfants
lisent le dimanche après-midi s'est
permis à la bibliothèque de tours
prochain rendez vous le 19 novembre